[Applause]
one question an amazing lineup of CEOs
Founders and experts this is marketing
for the now
[Music]
mark
you
Gary
how are you I'm good another marketing
for the now do you know that we're going
to be celebrating our third anniversary
in May isn't that crazy I do know that
Andrea that is something you know
we want to have you on for the full hour
I'm Gonna Catch You live here saying
that you might consider that for the
full hour in May we're gonna we're gonna
take a look at that
I might consider that okay all right
excellent say hello to Mikey D
um Vicky J's in the building Louis C uh
a bunch of great people art Ortega great
to see a lot Holly uh see him all in the
chat in the comments LinkedIn Facebook
YouTube we see you all here Ginger thank
you for the Hat comment
um all right Andrew go ahead and we're
fired up because they're all here
because they want to hear about social
platforms and culture and how we can be
relevant With Our Brands today but
before we kick off with some of our
favorite Brands we're gonna offer uh
Zach Nadler to come on up CEO of Vayner
speakers we want to hear a little bit
more about what's to come for vcon so
you got three minutes
we can go quick all right so uh Gary
he's working together 15 years this
August you've been to over a thousand
events
um the intent you know I think the
friends was created to make the world
friends with each other right patient
Panda and accountable aunt and all the
stuff we're working on with character
development animation kids books behind
the scenes that haven't been seen yet is
trying to make the world a better place
but in the short term V con was
structured to make people friends with
each other it was kind of like the
hippiness of Woodstock but the business
nature of Davos and South by and I think
last year we needed to really just
educate everybody on web3 and so last
year a lot of education on web3 this
year I think you're starting to see it
take its form and I think the energy of
the you know you and I talked about this
last year you were such I mean
you were as meaningful of a human You
Maha and like there were six or seven
people last year that had as big of an
impact on that being such a winning
event as I did and you were really there
and you were in the trenches and like
sweating and making it happen and then
at the end we looked at each other and
said this is insane how well this went
and of course that's like you and others
who did their thing but it was also the
intent of the energy of the audience and
I think it's just different and I think
anybody who's watching right now has
never bought an nft needs to figure out
how to buy an nft ticket get their ass
to Indianapolis because May 18th to the
20th is going to be crazy
yeah so 36 days out for everyone who's
not paying attention uh May 18th the
20th vcon.com tickets but let's be real
last year you had Snoop Dogg on stage
you were on stage with Wyclef singing at
one point but a stadium full of people
what was your favorite part about last
year that like the actual thing that was
going on was it connecting with all
these people and taking 5 000 selfies
like what really do you think people
need to know about vcon that you know
the intent was there people wanted to be
there but why is it v-con what makes it
so special
I think my favorite part was watching my
dad take all the things that people were
giving to me and taking it for himself
because he's a hoarder and he loves free
stuff
um it was just you know honestly you you
know me so well that you led the
question you know that while everyone
was like you're insane for you
know standing here for six and a half
hours without taking a drink of water
and taking selfies like I want that
one-on-one time with the community but
like for me it's like when I think about
I'll give you a great example Neil
Patrick Harris and Drew Barrymore
two of the speakers this year
like I know most people know Doogie
Hauser or like How I Met Your Mother I
know people know ET and Drew
Barrymore sure like I know that people
know them but people don't know them
and it was like what happened with Jesse
itzler last year right like my favorite
part is that the panels that you and I
have put together are banana the
content's banana everybody I will
talk about community and being friends
with each other all day long you know
this Zach and you won't we won't say it
because it's going to come across you
know egotistical but like
there's not a lot of events on Earth
that have the capacity of the speakers
we have uh like it's kind of scary
and you know so what makes it different
is it's one of the single best lineup of
speakers in the world with a community
that genuinely wants to be nice and and
we we're fixing like literally
everything was nice last year except
people bum rushing to the swag stations
and running each other over because they
want to flip life or they wanted this
stuff so like now we don't have limited
edition stuff but we have lots of stuff
like we're just gonna keep making it
nicer and we're gonna keep making it a
better quality content event
and the one thing you said to me was
afterwards you said all right great next
year let's make it bigger so we had 155
speakers last year we're gonna be close
to 200 this year so for those of you who
haven't seen we'll have another
announcement for you next week with our
final lineup but they're ready because
it's going to be it's gonna be out of
control thanks for getting in Europe
that was a fun little plug nice work
Andrea
I like the little commercial exactly
that we kick it off with a commercial
it's the preview I never look at the
schedule like what's that doing here
but don't worry thank you Zach and next
up we've got Mark Weinstein who is the
CMO at Hilton he oversees a portfolio of
7165 hotels across 19 brands in 123
countries welcome Mark but who's
counting
we like to count
you're one of those McDonald's how many
burgers we've sold uh signs and I gotta
up my swag game look at that shelf
because you're pretty good there brother
but this is actually I gotta add some
layers I gotta add some layers
uh real quick uh camel we have a new
office in the Amsterdam I see in the
comments Mark it's a real pleasure you
know obviously being the CMO of such an
iconic brand super cool let's just go
right into it what is your hot tea
actually I have a great question for you
mark because my team has been really
like I get debriefed on the majority of
meetings and it's been interesting to
see like how you know our team is a
tough filter because we're you know this
about us we're a very different
marketing firm than the the industry and
so we come from like a different angle
but I've been really impressed with kind
of the feedback of like the points of
view of my team about you to be frank
and so like I'm gonna ask you an
interesting question based on that
context
what helped the audience here that's a
mix of CMOS CEOs and entrepreneurs and
and influencers and young people what
is the disconnect between Fortune 500
brands
and and like where's the element of like
common sense that's me why do companies
struggle with doing good content on
social
because of the corporate element what
are they missing what's the Gap what are
you sensing what's your state of the
union on
creative on social is now where brand is
being built
a big companies are struggling to like
go pop committed that kind of happen why
it's like just your observation yeah you
know I I think at the core of it a brand
has to be really comfortable who they
are you know what their purpose is and
what their mission is but recognize we
have zero control of where customers
want to consume information and that
disconnect I think is what's causing the
challenge Gary I think the brands are
trying to push it out through channels
that traditionally people grew up with
and have believed in and known and yet
our customers are showing up in places
you wouldn't expect do you think that
brands are trying to stay on brand too
much and not be contextual to the
platforms and the tone and temperament
of consumer segregation yeah yeah yes I
mean our best marketing is when creators
tell their version of our story in
authentic ways right and instead of the
brand saying here's the script and
here's how it has to be done it has to
be shot this way and the lighting has to
be perfect reacting in the moment
creating lots of content some things
will fail and that's okay too I don't
think that's the typical cycle for a
major brand I think it's been so
traditionally
sort of purposeful and thoughtful and
three-year plans and we need to respond
this afternoon if something happens on
social and let other people tell our
story and trust that the authenticity
will outweigh the brand safety concerns
that come up along the way I think you
know at the core of your question Gary
influence has been democratized right
and that's the heart of what it is we
need to let the people who other folks
want to hear from hear from them what um
what platform or what cultural pop
culture phenomenon fashion trend up and
coming influencer uh the way people are
doing things TV show like what social
platform and or what pop culture
thing or movement has you personally
most intrigued
yeah you know we did some stuff on Tick
Tock recently and you know it could be
any platform that happens to be the one
that we were using in the moment where
the average length of viewership is a
couple seconds right and we had the
audacity to go to a 10 minute Tick Tock
and go look for 20 times the average
viewership by the time people spend
viewing we're going to tell our story
and we're going to push back and mock
the form itself and so the creators we
had the influencers we had were
embracing the the tropes and then
pushing back against them that was a lot
of fun that was a great way to tell our
story and really go we're in on the joke
you can wink and Nod at the customer and
go you know that the viewer and go look
we get that your customers and also
viewers that feels authentic that feels
true I think where you get in trouble is
when you try to teach a platform how
your brand Works uh or try to pull
everybody towards you that that doesn't
that doesn't ring true
and what's the biggest thing that has
surprised you in marketing in the last
five years
yeah you know maybe start with what
hasn't surprised me it's great
storytelling continues to win the day
right at the end of the day I get asked
on panels all the time what'll be next I
have no idea what technology what
platform will come next what format
it'll take is it voices but who cares
great stories will win the day and I
think it's been a reinforcement it's not
about stopping people where they are and
interrupting them it's about telling
stories in the way they want to consume
stories and so I love this again this
sort of democratization of how we
conduct our customers that's exactly
right it's why we're so we you know
we always say creative is the variable
of success
but the context of what creative you
have to make based on the new forms of
distribution whatever those forms may be
is where I think the industry is falling
we're we're romantic about subjective
quality and format and distribution in
the face of what everybody in these chat
comments are
living
well said I mean we're grading ourselves
against the scorecard we built 30 years
ago as an industry and customers are
going yeah
if these if these people knew that
everything in Fortune 500 marketing was
still based on a book written in 1991
they would laugh
yeah that's right and how do you have
enough confidence and conviction and
what your brand stands for that you can
let people play with it and feel
confident that it'll carry the day
that's been a difference for us in
telling our story about you know Hilton
for this day and our and our messaging
that in the world of go go go actually
taking a few minutes to reflect and stay
is actually quite powerful and the
antidote to everything else Society
wants you to do
I think that's right what um what uh
what do you tell inspiring
kids watching right now who absolutely
want to be the CMO of the big company
like you are what was a trick of the
trade what was a hack what was a tried
and true who was an impact how'd you get
here from your perspective look at you
know grind it out there is no shortcut
to this yeah it's a long game don't try
to get it tomorrow you know one thing I
tell folks all the time is
whenever there's a shiny object
everybody in the company wants to go
work on that project the new brand the
new product whatever it may be and
that's the least successful place you're
ever going to be it has the most
scrutiny on it it has the most pressure
associated with it go find the thing
that nobody else wants to do stay back
on goal go find the next project there's
more white space there's more room to
fail and by the way when that becomes
the next big thing you will have been in
the driver's seat and for me that's been
what it is it's just chipping away and
delivering along the way it's having big
visions of what we can achieve and
what's possible but putting wins on the
board one point at a time along the way
and that's how you earn your credibility
in your chops I think in these companies
in any company uh I think where folks
get a little bit off track is when they
try to jump steps when they sort of
worry about you know we'll be sitting on
the table we know our Frontline analysts
we know exactly what their capabilities
are we know who's going to be CMO one
day but if you think that way and you're
worried about it you're going to trip
along the way you're going to stumble
along the way versus just doing great
work day in day out taking the risks
being confident and what I would say
that the most young the the youngest of
our viewers fail early who cares right
at the end of the day I think we over
assess the risk of taking you know the
the penalty of taking a risk very very
low early in your career very very low
and so take lots of risks they can they
can perform quite well
but Mark thank you so much brother
thanks for being on continued success
and I hope you have a great summer yeah
you as well take care thanks Mark love
the last one now that now we're
celebrating epic fails all the time I
love that I agree before we uh get our
next guest about 30 seconds I want
everyone in the comments to say where
they live and what they do for a living
the networking I'm seeing potential here
on Facebook YouTube LinkedIn a bunch of
you have just joined for my tweet and my
Discord post please also get the value
from each other in this chat so please
uh let us know where you are from and
what you do uh love it I'm from
Wisconsin
Jersey via bellaries
all right it's time let's bring up Wanda
Young
she's the global Chief marketing and
experience officer for Ford Pro Ford Pro
provides an integrated lineup of all
kinds of things Vehicles Services
software charging and financing options
can't wait to hear more Wanda thanks so
much for joining us
hey Andrea how are you Wanda I'm loving
the pink yep I was just about to say
Wanda did they not tell you this is not
a fashion show like you really brought
it I mean this is I know I'm so excited
to be here Gary how's it going it's
going well it's actually just a
sweatshirt though is it no that's all it
is
right I get it
I love it Wanda um let's go right into
it you know from your perspective
sitting uh on top of one of the biggest
car companies in the world where is you
know big statement I don't think that's
quite true yeah a very senior role one
of the recognition of uh you know a 120
year old yes
okay I know you like to keep it humble
but the truth is you're sitting at a
very senior level at one of the biggest
car companies in the world
um
what is what is exciting and what is
challenging about the speed in which
these social platforms are changing you
know it's not just
you know okay there's snapping there's
Facebook and there's you know it's that
within them the algorithms are changing
constantly which is your distribution
and awareness
and the challenges creatively are
changing constantly give us some insight
to what a giant iconic company has
advantages in that environment or what's
extremely challenging in that
environment yeah the the biggest part is
like you just have to be relevant to
customers and like I remember talking to
somebody that I was trying to recruit in
and they're like yeah I'm a b2c marketer
I really can't come over and do this
thing that's B2B in Ford Pro we're
working with commercial customers and
they buy fleets and so we sell to like
the landscaper my electrician is
actually at my house he actually rang
the doorbell when I was supposed to be
coming into this and he he's like
driving up uh you know Ford Transit band
and so he's one guy with one van and
then we sell to Big fleets with you know
a thousand Vehicles so I have to look at
like who's our customer and determine
are they actually on snap I can tell you
this guy is not who's here
um but some of the dealers and some of
the customers that we're talking to
they're they're making Tick Tock videos
and you know trying to highlight what's
new and cool about the lightning so
we're trying to figure out what the
content's gonna be it's going to be
relevant to them you're right it is
about what's going to be relevant and
because the algorithms are changing how
do we stay on top of that and some of
the things that surprise me I posted
something about an electric school bus
from a work truck week event and I was
shocked at the number of
sales leads and questions I was getting
coming out of what I would have
considered to be pretty old school in
terms of who was walking through an
event at something that was Indiana
based called work truck week and the
people who followed me on Twitter who
were commenting and actually damning me
coming out of that event and by the way
Gary I didn't even go to the event and
it was about an electric school bus but
they're actually trying to transform how
they pick up and take our kids to school
and these people were coming from San
Jose California because they care about
how you know they're moving their
Journey on electrification and they want
to change so that's the behavior change
that you see happening that is
completely transforming the way people
think about content and what you would
not expect about that journey of content
followership the way that they think and
what they want to do with their
businesses entirely different
one um what about popular culture right
so now you decide okay cool like a tick
tock can actually you know we've gotten
to the era where 15 years later even the
biggest companies in the world a Pepsi a
BMW a Ford uh you know whatever it might
be they Now understand huh this social
media thing is not a toy this can be
real so we're there uh we're not fully
there I think a lot of people still
think of it as an afterthought but we're
kind of there then you gotta fill it
with content to your point
how much do you think this is actually a
great question that I'm curious about
your answer but I think is going to help
a lot of CMOS that watch this show
do you think that every brand including
B2B has permission to understand what's
happening in popular culture and find a
way to weave that into their
communication
isn't that a leading question
of course it is of course other than
other than you could say no
I mean I would definitely not say no I
was at the early stages of social media
working for Walmart trying to develop
them with a Facebook page for every
retail store I mean it has to be the
conversations occurring there it's got
to be an integrated part of conversation
we work to put in every single plan that
we're developing and um the reality is
the conversations start there first it's
not coming through a press release it's
going to get distributed through you
know news outlets um it begins there I
actually try we we work to develop
what's the customer journey and where do
they begin and oftentimes what I'm
usually teaching the teams that we work
with on on product management is
customer Journey Begins where it is
online and it's going to begin through a
platform pick one and there's they're
starting their searches whether it's
through Google and whatever and then map
it from there onward and that's how we
start and then we have to think through
what are all the touch points that
they're going to go through from there
so we always talk about what the
customer journey is going to be and by
the way it doesn't matter if it's B to b
or b2c it's just people they're like we
don't Market to buildings so it is a
customer conversation and how they're
getting there and you know
um I follow this there's this really
weird guy that I knew that was doing
these wine journals and he's talked
about like a Wine Library it's a really
odd guy he's been doing like thousands
of these videos over the course of the
years you might know who he was
um and uh we weirdly uh worked with the
Sonoma County weingers Association and
you wouldn't think that wine and trucks
go together you don't drive when you're
doing this
I've shipped a lot of wine around the
country through trucks trucks are a very
important part of how my wine Farmers
left their trucks but these wine Growers
um we started working with them as when
we launched the Sonoma
um we were launching the Ford Pro brand
and we went out there and so at all
types of people who are driving trucks
and vans are working on their journey to
electrification and they people that you
wouldn't think are beginning this
conversation but they started online
across platforms and they came to us and
found us by looking online saying look
F-150 Lightning had to start this and
you know why because they want to lower
their emissions footprint and they're
looking to deliver a new way of actually
doing something as old as farming and
take this their business in a different
direction it's all kinds of businesses
small medium large government Enterprise
and so we're helping them do this but
this conversation begins with what they
find when they go and look for companies
and businesses who can deliver you know
what we talk about is really just it's a
One-Stop shop and that's how we we start
the conversation with them interesting
what about longer form content for
something that is you know when I think
about lowering emissions and you know
electric vehicles and things that nature
is there back to social platforms has
there been a thought or how do you think
about or does the company think about
longer form content that then gets
chopped down to your point even earlier
about the school bus
the concept of in a B2B environment for
all the B2B marketers here filming the
trade show
to then create the clips from the
conversations at the trade show to be
content they're putting out on YouTube
and Linkedin
um please oh my electrician's here do
you want to meet him I'd love to say
hello yeah hey anyway it's scary
um I kind of just talk to you in about
10 minutes that's great so can I say hi
to Lloyd no he's he just walked out
though I just have to talk to Mattress
he's working on my garage door and he um
we do that a lot we actually filmed a
lot of customers when we're at the trade
show we actually just do an intercept
and then we talk to them about their
business because the whole point about
getting to authentic content um I heard
you was talking a little bit ago
um with Hilton and the authenticity of
actually capturing like what are their
real what are the real challenges their
business they I mean when you talk about
um I know you have a love for you know
um small businesses in particular and
when you think about what they're
dealing with we try and get behind like
the real issues I mean we talk all the
time I I'm go out and travel with our
sales teams and we go and visit with
them about like you know through the um
the the challenges going into the
recession fuel is a real issue as they
um are taking their trucks and bends and
they have to keep them for a lot longer
because the fact that by the way I don't
know if anybody heard but there was a
chip crisis and we haven't been able to
all oems haven't been able to actually
deliver the trucks and vans have been
promised so for those issues
um it's been the rising cost of fuel
major issue repairs have taken a lot
longer to get them in and out of all of
the garages and so customers have really
been dealing with that so when they try
they start thinking about well maybe I
need to go hybrid maybe I need to so
they're out researching and looking to
get a lot of help as they're trying to
figure out how to go electric and
they've been looking at Ford and Ford
Pro to figure out well can I get some
help on the Consulting of this they need
to figure out and it takes months to get
electricians to help install you know
the right type of chargers how do they
get this done with the city and
permitting and this takes it can take
six to nine months to get through that
process so they have real issues trying
going to install all of the software and
the service to get all of that put
together they need a lot of support
they're out scrubbing YouTube looking
for the right support and help on that
so that's why we are
in this last second based on everything
you just said is AI becoming an
important conversation because you
realize you can map that and make it
much more efficient for people we have a
team internally they have a we have a
proprietary tool internally that is um
developing a solution for us and it
actually takes all of the Ford jargon
and it has built on an AI platform that
we're utilizing and actually building it
to help us support our contact center
is that actually something we're using
for our contact centers to support to
develop it so that we can do better
online support and working to integrate
that into some of our online chat as
well
Wanda thank you thanks
that was great I think it's Gary's
electrician is calling him right now my
boss
that was lovely thanks to you both
thanks Gary for joining all right it's
time for Ryan Harwood Ryan oh my God
Ryan it's I feel like it's been too long
man it's been a while it has been a
while it's good to have you back thank
you before we spin off your own show
here
Ryan is the CEO of gallery Media Group
our publishing entity at Vayner and Ryan
I'm super fired up today we have aleko
asqueta who's going to be joining us
let's bring him up he has quite a story
he's the VP of marketing for great Goose
North America and after being eight
years an entrepreneur he's now come full
circle back to Bacardi limited where he
started his career in 1998 that is so
cool cheers to you aleko thank you
how you doing aleko what's up Ryan
everything good everything's great
everything's great thanks for having me
on yeah absolutely surviving this
hideous weather down in Miami right now
yeah so we've actually had like three
straight days of rain which is uh pretty
uncommon for us but uh you know
obviously most of the year it's Paradise
down here so no complaints I'm actually
down here with you right now which is
why I'm looking out the window and I'm
like Jesus I have to go back to New York
on Saturday give me something down here
come here well it's good it's good
Martini weather yeah indeed awesome well
let's jump right into this I'm excited
to have you on because I'm a big fan of
the brand
um you know you've been with Bacardi for
years how have you seen the company's
viewpoint on audience change over the
years
yeah no great great question because
it's a hot topic for us um I really
think like honestly as a whole I don't
think the audience per se has changed I
think the way we look at our business is
we have to continuously always be
recruiting into the the brand so
audience saves the state I think what's
really changed is the way that we
connect
um with the audience you know when I
started 20 years ago I could do print
ads uh the TV spot and I'm reaching 90
of the audience that I want to now it's
a lot more nuanced and I think before we
used to broadcast our message now now we
really have to rely on a lot of other
mediums especially within social working
with influencers
um and so we can connect
um with the audience that we're trying
to to recruit in a really relevant and
organic way yep makes total sense and I
know that music
it's a huge part of your marketing
strategy for you you know you're the
spirit of the Grammys you know tell us
what does that mean for the brand and
consumer and why did you choose that as
a pillar
yeah for sure so the Grammys uh we're
gonna go on we're two years that we've
been the official Spirit of the Grammys
uh obviously when you look at the
Grammys it really is like the Super Bowl
of culture
um and really what goes perfect I mean
consuming like you know high-end uh
Spirits with music they it goes hand in
hand it's a celebratory moment
um and for us we've all always
um really looked at music to celebrate
creators expressiveness
um and the Grammys in particular is just
an awesome event for us besides being
such like a cultural moment uh it allows
us to really have full-on 360 activation
you know from the event itself where we
can serve our products so we have a
signature drink and the passion drop we
have content that we create specifically
um with them and then we can also do
broad reach media because I do still
believe in TV I think in the right time
it does allow you to have broad reach so
we can actually advertise in show
um but what happens with TVs is as you
know nowadays you know consumers really
have a control you can watch anything
whenever you want you can click on and
off but where they really do lean in
it's live sporting events or award shows
like the Grammys so that so that's why
for us it makes
um a lot of sense um to do
um and then personally just uh you know
because a lot of this is personal too
I'm a big fan of Music in general and uh
and it's nice to be able to go to the
Grammys and and see your brand come to
life there I appreciate that
same reason that I show up to the uh the
US Open each year which we'll get to
exactly you guys are a big part of that
um you know I'd be remiss if I didn't
ask you about the rise of ready to drink
and ready to serve cocktails like how do
you think about that Trend rising and
how is that going to impact your
business overall yeah no I mean it's
been like a game changer really
um in our business uh because I I think
um especially when you look at a lot of
people used to come into high and spear
Spirits in general through through beer
um but now what you're seeing is you
know you have a lot of like spirit-based
rtds or even like white Claws and truly
people are think that they're already
um you know have Spirits in them so that
to me is like one you're already like a
step closer
um as well then the other thing that
happened is uh with RTS for people don't
know that's that's more ready to serve
so that's not in the can so that's a
cocktails in a bottle and people really
want to create that experience that they
have in like a high-end bar for example
or a restaurant with a cocktail at home
um but our insights show for example
there are 20 million Americans that own
a martini shaker but they're like
intimidated to use it it looks cool but
they don't know how to use it so we
actually launched uh this month uh a
Gray Goose classic martini in about
model where we're really offering
consumers a perfect Martini every time
like in a bottle so it's a really
exciting Innovation for us
um we think people will you know want to
do it because it demystifies the martini
but it's also very organic it's not like
we're creating something that's not part
of the Brand's DNA
um with the Greg's classic martini
makes a lot of sense you know and I'm
I'm always interested in people's take
on this you know you oversee a highly
venerable brand uh
you know it's been around a while even
when I was in college it was the hottest
drink ever like how do you remain
relevant over time with such a venerable
brand like Gray Goose yeah I mean really
that's the the Crux of my existence uh
and day to day so uh I first and
foremost it really starts like with the
team
um you know as a middle-aged person
trying to recruit uh new consumers into
Gray Goose
um I I need to have a team of like super
smart young diverse at a reflection of
our consumer you know the consumers that
were actually you know trying to be
relevant with so it starts with that um
as well and then um you know I think you
also have to be comfortable like seeding
control like of your brand everything's
not always going to be like totally on
brand on point so that's why we work
with you know influencers that you know
they have their own audience but they
want to speak to Their audience not in a
brand voice but in their voice so you
have to be comfortable with that and
then we also align
um with certainly like cultural
platforms so we we're partners with uh
Lebron James uh and Maverick Carter's
show the shop on uninterrupted so it's
basically really raw open conversations
um but you have to be comfortable as a
brand person that is you're not always
going to have be on brand like on
message the way you would normally
perceive it to be but your message is
coming across in a way that's relevant
um to the people that are taking in the
show because they're tuning in to hear
the conversations not to learn about
your brand so your brand needs to be
there in a way that's organic and
authentic yep
and last question here before I do a
quick speed round you know yeah I
brought up the US Open before it's one
of my favorite events of the Year by far
um The Gray Goose honey Deuce cocktail
is the drink of that event
it's made waves for a while just in
culture in general I mean how did you
get the brand so entrenched in a
cultural event like that and and how
does that impact the business or how you
show up elsewhere at other events
yeah I think
um the U.S open we're going on year 17
with the partnership so consistency I
think is a big part of it I think too
many too often um Brands will be in and
out versus forming like long-term
Partnerships with Brands
um the other great thing about the US
Open is unlike a football game or
something where last call is for example
at halftime sometimes like the matches
go into two three in the morning
um so that also gives people an
opportunity at I think we have a stat
that a honey Deuce has sold every three
seconds uh at the US Open which is
pretty amazing uh and we really didn't
even realize how big of a part of the
U.S open it was
um until the pandemic hit and there
weren't audience people allowed at the
U.S open so we actually created honey
Deuces to go in conjunction with the
USDA
um and that also LED now that we have
like through cocktail Courier you can
actually have honey Deuces like ordered
uh to your home but yeah it's been great
I mean it's uh I don't think you can
experience a US Open without a great use
honeyduce you cannot all right awesome
quick speed round it's what I'm known
for today and why these guys keep
inviting me on to an interview people so
here we go early riser or night owl yeah
at this stage in my life probably more
of an early riser even though I still
probably go to bed a little later than I
should
so you're an always honor yeah Instagram
or Tick Tock for personal consumption
yeah um personal it's still probably a
little more IG but uh but Tick Tock is
very much a guilty pleasure that that'll
get sucked into quite often
you never leave home without
I live in Miami I have to say my
Ray-Bans yeah I always got to bring the
shades with me and lastly how do you
drink your Gray Goose of gregus Martini
uh stirred with a Twist
aleko thank you so much for joining us
we appreciate it
awesome thank you Ryan that was fun
that was fantastic I'm not going to
forget that that honey dew statistic is
a is a crazy one right crazy whoa I love
those all right but let's bring another
beverage brand up shall we Ryan let's go
all right let's bring Michael Smith up
he is head of marketing for one of
pepsico's newest Brands Starry which is
a lemon lime soda which is poised for
major disruption Michael thanks for
joining us and if you can't tell Ryan
he's he's calling in live from Hudson
yards yeah let's go he's in my office
right now
what's up Michael I'm doing well man and
uh happy to be here both virtually and
physically
I love it I love it Michael one of my
favorite people in the marketing world
you remind me you're a Knicks fan right
or no I'm a Knicks fan It's Been a Good
Year I'm excited I'm excited for
Saturday night let's go Knicks just for
everyone in the audience you gotta root
for Knicks absolutely
all right thanks for joining us today
I'm super curious to learn more about
Starry given how new it is and how you
guys are thinking about the brand you've
made a big splash on a sport that I love
so you know tell me you just launched
this new soda brand it's a very crowded
beverage Market tell me how you looked
at platforms how you looked at culture
when you were preparing to launch story
in order to inform your decision making
yeah it's a great question and it's a
crowded Marketplace and I think the
first thing that we try to do is say
where are we trying to win
um and so we really focused on the lemon
lime category stories uh lemon lime soda
so we said first and foremost let's win
in our category
um and from there we can win more
broadly in the beverage phase and then
you know to your point around platforms
I think
you know for us it was about who's
underserved who's not being seen who do
we have an opportunity to create a real
and authentic relationship with who's
going to embrace our brand because you
know the category is not talking to them
Brands aren't talking to them or Brands
aren't showing up there and so being you
know a new brand at the marketplace we
were looking for white space we were
looking for white space from a platform
perspective we were looking for white
space from a consumer perspective and
you know what we really saw
um when we started to peel the onion a
little bit is especially in our category
there's one really dominant player it's
been around for a very long time
um but it isn't necessarily
representative of younger consumers in
the marketplace and so we said you know
there's an opportunity where you know
you don't necessarily want to have your
mom's lemon lime soda so there there was
a an opportunity for us to act as a
badge for a younger generation and then
we said okay you know where do they live
where do they spend time and you know
that became really easy for us and so
you know we looked at the tick tocks the
reels the the YouTube shorts of the
world and said you know we can win in
this space where by the way our
competitors aren't playing and where the
consumer that we want to embrace is
naturally living like let's show up
there and let's break the Playbook a
little bit around how you would launch a
soda brand especially coming from you
know a company like PepsiCo in order to
authentically show up in the lives of
those consumers but that's really how we
thought about it I love it and as I
mentioned earlier you guys chose the NBA
you chose all-star weekend to launch
Starry in a big way you know what was
the process like in in which you picked
that cultural event and what were you
looking to achieve throughout the
weekend when you when you went there
yeah you know it's another great
question and there's
I mean I guess it's an age-old marketing
tension but it shows up in our world a
lot we want to be specific to a Target
consumer that we're really looking to
act as a voice for but we also have a
responsibility as we think about how we
need to grow our business to find the
right mainstream platforms to drive
awareness and you know with Starry being
a new to the world trademark like
they're not that many times where you
get to launch something wholly new and
like our Innovation development process
is almost 18 months long so we're
sitting with it right it to us it's not
new it's something that's existed for a
really long time and we have to remember
that you know for consumers every
consumer that sees Dari this year it's
probably going to be the first time they
interact with that brand it's not a line
extension it's a truly new trademark and
so we needed to find the right place
where we felt like we could be authentic
to our audience but also show up you
know in a big way and on a large stage
and so we we felt that all-star weekend
was the right way to do that um the MBA
is the most impactful sports League
amongst young consumers basketball is a
lifestyle as much as it is a sport so we
felt like it was the right place for
Starry to be
and then the all-star weekend is the
crown jewel of their season maybe
outside of the finals and so there are
all eyes on the NBA over the course of
that weekend so we felt like it was
right from a Target perspective we felt
like it was right from a scale
perspective and then we said how do we
go big so we integrated across the board
everything from owning the Three-Point
Contest to launching our first ad
campaign to activating on the ground to
giving out almost a million samples of
Starry
to partnering with over 15 athletes over
the course of the weekend like is like
we're going to be at every touch point
for people on the ground and for people
tuning in and so you weren't going to be
able to miss us and it was the right
place for us to be
you know as I scroll through
Tick Tock you know there's there's so
many beverage challenges soda challenges
taste tests you know people are fanatic
about what they drink how do you keep
relevant when the competition is this
fierce in this type of category
you know it's a great question I I would
I would throw that one back at you like
you give me the answer um
it's one of those things that for us
like
we don't know and so you have to you
have to get yourself out of the
historical marketing model of you're
going to spend six months nine months
designing a campaign and you're gonna
think through every eventuality of that
campaign and then you're going to push
it out into the world and yeah you're
gonna cross your fingers that that
people accepted and that you hit on
something at the right time you know for
us when we think about how to be
successful on Tick Tock how to break
through given everything that's going on
and the speed of culture is we've
decided to do essentially two things and
those two things are based on you know
us accepting the reality that we don't
know what's gonna hit and we can't
design something to hit every single
time and so we've done two three two
things first we've brought an entirely
new process to our organization that
allows us to you know streamline the
decision-making hierarchy in order to
develop produce and publish content
faster so we've Stripped Away a lot of
the obstacles and barriers to moving
fast and that's really really helped us
and then secondarily we've decided that
we're going to produce that volume and
at scale because we have no idea like
what's going to win there's nothing I
find you know funnier than sitting in
you know a creative review for social
content and it's just like I don't know
man like let's do it
um does it feel like it's relevant is is
there some buzzing some heat around it
is it you know a conversation or a
concept or an idea or a trend you know
that we can have a unique point of view
on all right let's do it and let's
continue to test and learn like The Tick
Tock algorithm is the biggest focus
group probably in the history of
marketing and let's leverage it as a
focus group and let's continue to throw
stuff at it
um to see what works and hopefully we
get better over time but for us it was
really about
how do we operate at scale and then how
do we structure our organization and our
teams to allow for that
um and the more that we do that the more
of an opportunity we have to be
successful yeah it's an and statement
not an or statement keep creating keep
creating and let let the algorithm tell
you what consumers actually like I love
it
um last question here tell me about your
own personal consumption habits and and
just kind of interaction with culture
like where are you engaging with the
culture of right now in order to you you
know try to just learn in general
you know it's a great question and a
bound over the course of my career
hopefully I've gotten better at
marketing and I've probably gotten worse
at culture and the reality is as we all
get older like that just kind of happens
like I cannot I can no longer trust
myself to be able to look at something
and say that's cool yeah people are
digging that like it's the reality of
aging and so I've tried to to move away
from that I now find myself more as a
boy or Boyer of culture
um and so there are two things that are
really important to me and one obviously
honestly is more about mental health
thing I I'm All About Touch grass and
like you gotta just get outside and like
spend time with people spend time out in
the world in the physical world that to
me is really important it it helps me
from a mental health perspective but
still being able to see how people
engage you know how they dress
um how they behave like there's no to me
there's no anecdote for actually being
out in the world and then secondarily
man I'm scrolling Tick Tock like I
really am
um and so the the algorithm's fitting me
for sure but um that's where culture is
happening right now and it's where I'm
spending the most of my time so it's
talking to people in the real world and
then scrolling I like it I like it
awesome speed round for you time right
now here we go are you an early riser or
a night owl
I'm an early riser now man again like
getting older and so there's there's
nothing better than you know a coffee at
six a.m these days I like it okay
personal consumption are you spending
more time on Instagram or Tick Tock
these days
I spend more time in IG DMS and more
time just broadly scrolling Tick Tock as
an entertainment platform it's super
interesting
um you never leave home without this
airpods every day can't walk out the
door without them if I lose them I'm
going directly to the Apple Store like
have to be in my pocket last one ice
cubes or crushed ice
okay as a former athlete if I'm icing a
body part crushed ice if I'm putting ice
in a drink ice cubes I love it I love it
thank you Michael I appreciate you let's
go Knicks absolutely man appreciate it I
loved Ryan's face when he was talking
about the crushed icos like he couldn't
wait to hear what your answer was and I
don't know I don't know about the
crushed ice thing for injuries I gotta
try that it's a good one all right it is
can't thank you enough both of you for
joining this is fantastic thank you so
much
all right we next up we have
Chris Anthony Chief Revenue officer from
Gallery Media Group hi Chris how you
doing hi Andre how are you good to see
you it's nice to see you too looks like
you're somewhere exciting I'm not just a
home but I need my own trademark routing
lightning ride like Ryan he's like oh
yeah I need my own trademark version I
know well you know what I think we let
him do that we'll do our own thing
you're gonna have your own show You're
Gonna Do Your Own Thing well and yeah
and with you guys you can actually
produce it so it's all good all right
next we have June up Jun Lee ricer she
uh she is the GM I have to look at it
because it's such a long time GM and EVP
for the premium Skin Care Division of
Crown Laboratories
June is a skin expert and digital
innovator with a proven track record for
growth Juno is blown away by some of the
stories that you were telling me about
the science and how you guys are looking
at all kinds of areas that I wasn't even
thinking about in my life so we're very
excited to have you on the show today
thanks for joining thank you for having
me I'm so excited
hi June how are you good to see you
great to see you it's a beautiful day
here in Dallas so happy to be talking to
you I know in New York as well it is
spring is here we'll take it I'm excited
supposedly 83 in New York on Friday so
it's great but yes let's Jump Right In
because with lots of exciting stuff to
talk about and so many of the great work
that you're doing at the brand
um so much today is talking about
obviously relevance and culture but I
think a lot of things have to obviously
have to be a North star around a mission
and a purpose talk a little bit about
that and how that sort of gets you to
relevance
absolutely and I am so proud to work on
this amazing skincare brand called
StriVectin and when we think about being
relevant as a brand to our consumers it
really I think starts with what you
stand for and having that vision and
purpose and a true differentiated
identity and really proud to say also
that StriVectin has stood the test of
time it's been around now for over 20
years as a science-based clinical
efficacious brand that is helping
consumers with skin skin health problems
and really delivering powerful products
with visible results and I think that
that is something that is so fundamental
to the success of StriVectin and when
you have that North Star and the vision
of how you're helping consumers with
your products that really drives
everything and it's been a growth engine
for us
um however you still need to constantly
be innovating yes you know you've got
some Power Products in our portfolio
I'll give you an example Chris we have
the number one neck cream in America
it's an amazing product for tightening
um and lifting the neck a lot of
consumers don't realize that the neck is
so sensitive and we're bringing this
amazing product it's been out there for
quite some time but you can't rest on
your laurels in order to stay relevant
with consumers you want to innovate and
certainly impressive skin care
Innovation is critical and so we took
that platform to Not Just Launch things
that may be trendy but don't necessarily
tie to what your brand stands for so we
took the idea of a neck cream and we
launched a neck roller serum in a
different format for the neck and the
jawline last year it was one of the most
successful new products in Christ skin
care so knowing what you stand for and
having that North Star but then
constantly innovating I think is
absolutely critical to being relevant
for consumers today
yeah and to your point Innovation goes
so well with this topic and especially
in the category it's driving all the
growth so congrats on that and all the
new product revolutions staying on that
topic of innovation and sort of what
that means in the platform space talk a
little about Tick Tock I'm a little
familiar obviously given our
relationship on that platform but what
are you learning from that platform
what's it sort of teaching you guys
about
um the consumers the product talk a
little bit about that platform
specifically
absolutely Tick Tock is so great as a
platform for listening and learning
um you know one of the key pieces that
our marketing team does really well is
to listen to the conversations that are
out there and being part of the
conversation versus trying to create a
topic that may not be as relevant and so
we use tick tock specifically to listen
to what are consumers talking about what
are they engaging on and in the world of
skin care it's incredible Chris how much
education is sought after
um another example is there's a huge
conversation on basic things like how to
wash your face what is the right skin
care routine what's the right order of
products that you need to use um huge
debates in terms of cleansing maybe
double cleansing adding eye creams
serums moisturizers SPF and so one of
the most successful Tick Tock videos
that strike Upton launched in
partnership with your agency was
specifically talking about skin care
routines the right order the right
products and that generated such an
incredible conversation online so Tick
Tock is great not just to have your
brand message out there but really to
learn and engage in conversations that
consumers are already having
and makes everything feel easy and easy
in a complex world of some some of these
things so that's such an amazing
Discovery tool in that aspect on the
same vein obviously you guys are a
global brand and of such great presence
everywhere shopping and commerce and all
that has just changed so much over the
years especially over the last three
years how does it work in terms of you
really thinking about being relevant on
all the different shopping behaviors and
different channels talk a bit about that
yes one example I can talk about is our
explosive growth in China
um that is a market that we are growing
in and in terms of how we're engaging
with consumers and shopping because
omnichannel has been out there for some
time and yes we have a strivectin.com
direct to Consumer we have brick and
mortar our focus is specialty retailers
but in a market like China live
streaming is critical and we've seen
incredible success by partnering with
key opinion leaders kol's
um one in particular Austin Lee
um and we're leaning into those major
live streaming events like double 11 618
where you can sell thousands of units of
StriVectin double fix for lips in
minutes and so really just staying on
top of where is the consumer and being
everywhere she wants to shop and in
China that means live streaming strive
acting is a global brand and just
staying on top of all the different
platforms and engaging with how she
wants to shop and that's critical
because there might be a new form of
shopping opportunities going forward
there are a lot of things that we're
really Keen to just keep our eye on and
be externally focused this is something
I really stress to my teens and I think
we do really well which is yes you wanna
really have internal conversations
processes and go to market strategies
but let's focus on the outside let's
bring the outside in let's figure out
what's important to the consumer where
is she shopping be in those platforms
and then when it comes to influencers
kol's in China choosing the right ones
that really have integrity and know your
brand and authentically use your brand
and love the brand and therefore can be
a great advocate for your brand on
platforms Like A Team all and live
streaming event
so so great um the live shopping space
is so interesting and fascinating so
it's so exciting you guys are very
obviously early on in the right space
there last question obviously we talked
about Tick Tock and there's a lot of
inspiration coming there what else sort
of inspires you as a leader as a
marketer from a from a culture
standpoint right now where you're
getting some inspiration as you're
thinking about what's next for the brand
well we're always looking at diverse
audiences and consumers I think that one
of the things that we're really excited
about with StriVectin is expanding our
consumer audience and we're looking at
behavioral audiences but we're also
making sure that we're relevant across
and so staying close to Consumers
listening whatever platforms they're on
we do a lot of social listening that is
critical for us because we have
consumers that are seeking us for let's
say Anti-aging products but we also just
launched an acne range so let's talk to
those consumers who have blemish prone
skin they're on potentially different
platforms and having different
conversations and so really just trying
to expand our Audience by listening and
seeing how can our brand intersect with
those needs and because we stand for
Science and we stand for products that
really work and our launches need to be
super relevant this year we're launching
an acne range also even a range for
keratosis Polaris so just staying close
to the consumer because that was rough
and bumpy skin was a was a need that we
saw was out there and there wasn't
really a product and brand that had the
Integrity like StriVectin and to be able
to address that concern of rough and
bumpy skin so it's just exciting times
to work on StriVectin and be part of
um you know the prestige skincare space
and just be relevant in today's culture
yeah it's so great and just the amount
of Science and the work that goes in the
brand is so incredible so congrats to
all that and all the amazing work and
everything that's to come but thank you
so much for joining us today awesome
thank you it was fun
thank you June the the comments are
going wild you got a lot of I think some
new customers that need to be checking
out some things Innovation is is
fantastic I'm going for the neck thing
absolutely
fantastic thanks for joining June and
thank you Chris as always thanks Andre
have a good see you soon all right take
care and thanks all of you for joining
us we are going to be celebrating our
three-year anniversary of marketing for
the now on May 9th we already have an
outstanding lineup so we hope you can
make it 12 noon eastern time so sign up
and don't be shy let us know if there
are other people you want on the show
what topics might be of interest and we
can't thank you enough for joining us
today
see you soon